a mouse on a cat on a dog and chocolate
sprinkles it's episode 29 of IMG trick
people into thinking you have a six pack
or throw your crumbled-up bad ideas into
the blinds to make a skull then swim
with an eight and spot the difference
there's no need to panic it's under
control completely
these pepperonis are hearts and so is
the pizza and these guys don't mind
Heights of course neither does this guy
go don't mind me I'm just walking my
squirrel like a box here have a snack
hipster dog and soybean photographer Tom
priors dog hates dinosaurs and doesn't
trust tubes with eyes on them either
but I guess that's life in 2011 chest
hair take a trip to exotic oh boy look
use the pause button to read college
humors investigation of April O'Neil but
here's Snoop Dogg huh nice Adie calm
collected the most useful tattoos rulers
pie and eye charts you can read with
glasses oh and also connect the dots
nice and now
fashion my girlfriend and absolute
brilliance oh look
Michel keep it down I'm brooding okay
sorry but still pretty cool huh
guess what though I'm not done
scrambling your brain yet this guy is
levitating except actually that's just a
stain on the cement here's a dance class
of course the dancers are kind of dirty
and what's scary about this scene we'll
try upping the brightness to reveal what
the fun times stealing clothes but then
again just set down your rice Chex wheat
Chex and corn Chex and realize they line
up let's montage it up with Justin
Bieber pillows I mean people arrested
during haircuts
I mean pictures of kids recreated years
later when they're adults done very very
well
and now slink to choose little figuring
people boarding UFOs killing big-game
skateboarding
boating and jamming to music in episode
27 I asked you guys to recommend
celebrity mix-and-match body parts for
me to photoshop for you I see say you
asked for Barack Obama's head on
Beyonce's body wearing mr. team bling
dress like Duke Nukem and Robert meal TV
suggested Justin Bieber's hair and
hathaways body Charlie Sheen's face and
Scooby Doo's tail I leave you with
historical facts from the Smithsonian
subscribe to vsauce for more knowledge
and as always thanks for watching
you